[Music]
a ukrainian millionaire
is asking the air force to bomb his own
mansion the ukrainian air force because
i don't want to pay for demolition
it's too much they want to charge me
thirty thousand dollars he's trying to
kill his wife yeah as you think wife
kill whatever i think he wants cheap
demolition because he wants he's like
i hated this [ __ ] or you want some
insurance payments
they didn't even listen to my
imagination why do you think that he
would do that insurance payout oh it
turns out
he got he got insurance but they know
he's asking so he'll be fried then like
uh i don't know keep on down low dude
who's this snitch that wrote about this
yeah
let's talk about that [ __ ] guy this
reporter this whistleblower amazing he
well he also was on a ukrainian morning
show asking them to do it like he's it's
like a public he's publicly asking can
you just blow up my mansion well
actually he was publicly like uh talking
about how he asked them to do it so it's
like it's news now is it because it got
uh used by the russian forces that's it
okay
yeah so it's been tarnished he wasn't
there at the time but he could see on
his security cameras this is right that
the russian forces took it over
and then
they captured his like security staff in
the building and then they he like they
like stripped the security let them walk
into the forest like they released them
but then they started using it like as a
some kind of operation and so they're
like blow up my baby yeah that's kind of
[ __ ] jesus he could see it happening
he was like that's the new target blow
it up they're all in there take them out
damn that all the fighter pilots want to
like who wants to bloat the mansion
good morning ukraine just talking [ __ ]
like yo you guys gotta blow up my
[ __ ] house wouldn't they know like
when the russians know maybe they're not
watching it they're watching good day
ukraine
oh we gotta get out of here they're like
what's on the tv by the time it was on
tv they had already done it
oh
that's kind of fire can you imagine
being the [ __ ] dude on rings going
like hey
you stealing my house man
and then you're on ring like get out
beach
no stay in there
[Laughter]
yeah that's
crazy crazy yeah they said there was a
it he saw like 12 russian military
vehicles and high-powered weapons holy
[ __ ] including like the guys that were
in there they loaded all this they took
a bunch of [ __ ] too like to use that
supplies
they looted a bunch of other homes in
the area as well they like took all the
tvs the ipads i mean it is
war yes
but what would you do with a big [ __ ]
tv like in war right like how are you
going to take that back to russia
that's a bit you just you got it you're
like look at this [ __ ] 7d screen you
know i got the 70 incher man come on
fell off the truck right that way
[Laughter]
fell off the truck
they got to put that in their tank
and they still got a war to fight so
they're just running around with a big
screen tv imagine how that must feel
like though to like in the middle of a
war to see not robbers in your home but
a whole other
armed force take your house over yeah
it's like it's like what was that one
movie the [ __ ] um
red dawn it's like that but like for
real for real
olympus has fallen bro they took over
the white house in that movie that's a
big deal
they didn't even watch it is that gerard
butler i don't know
i have a neighbor in in hollywood who
she's got this like
she has the biggest house in our area
huge uh it's an old couple that lives
there they're both doctors
and her house is so big that one day she
was in there by herself and she was
setting the alarm like arming it and it
wouldn't arm because alarms don't arm
when they're detecting movement and she
was like what the [ __ ] did she start
like
she's like what the hell's going on she
looked at her camera people were in her
house robbing it while she was in there
by herself damn that's crazy and it's
just such a big house she doesn't it's
so big
it's so big and there's just two people
this gigantic house how did she what did
she do call the cops
she has a room that's called the
government to vomit she was like two
blocks away you craig where you at
how fast you get here now it has a panic
room
but what if the robbers were closer to
the panic room and she had to pass them
to get to the panic there's like a delay
in the feed they're already in there
yeah i know she went straight in there
and like uh yeah she called the cops
they came then she emailed our group
email and we were all like what the [ __ ]
did they catch the guys yeah they got
them okay what they were like they were
just like a group of homeless guys they
were squatting like the area and then
they they got to her house yeah homeless
guys in the millionaire's neighborhood
wow that's the that's the million dollar
problem i saw um this security business
that installs like custom things for
millionaires and they were showing some
of the [ __ ] they had it's [ __ ] wild
dude like some guys they get machine
guns installed in the wall like a drone
gun yeah and then you could control it
from your [ __ ] phone
so if they see intruders coming in they
can just press a button and it shoots
through the wall that's from call of
duty bruh dude it's some crazy [ __ ] is
that like would you not get
i guess it's more you got they probably
have so much it's under booby trap loss
so it's all yeah so you're home alone
yeah it's on the home alone clause
if it's like [ __ ] pearl necklace on
the ground and he slips on it it's okay
you know what you see a lot in vegas so
there's those like super baller
communities and on those houses you'll
see like uh on top of the window there's
like this big like canister thing and
it's a metal roll down door like just
like the one we have out here so it'll
cover like because i think a lot of
those ballers that's not the only home
they have they have homes all over the
world so they might not be there for
like six months at a time so when
they're leaving they don't want anyone
breaking in through the glass or
whatever so outside of the windows if
you pay attention to some of the baller
homes they have the
metal roll-up doors so if they roll all
of them down you're good then
technically you're impenetrable like you
can't no one could break the glass you
don't need to get out they can't get in
yeah you don't need anyone to go check
up on your house because it's literally
like just every entry point is blocked
so it's like the purge so no one can
zipline into their window anymore yeah
batman can get in there yeah they're
gonna hit that [ __ ] metal gate and be
like [ __ ] and they fall you could still
[ __ ] through the chimney
that's what i got that's that's the only
downside you have steel toe boots
kick the [ __ ] out of it
you'll get in there
doc martin's getting in
there i would zip line with my [ __ ]
steel toes like this
there's like a detective that's like
looking over there and going
somebody with docs was here
someone would talk marks trying to kick
the [ __ ] out of this wall must have been
a skinhead
american history x guys looks like we
got ourselves a hate [ __ ]
yeah did i ever tell you the story about
the freaking squatter across the street
from where i lived in hollywood no six
months she lived in there and we thought
it was just our neighbor oh wow that's
crazy she was this girl that was like
there was like a vacant home uh like you
said some people that own hollywood
hills houses are just never there they
own like eight houses yeah so then um
she breaks in this girl with like dreads
white girl with dreads
we thought she was like a cool artist
was she spitting her hair all the time
doing this hey guys
she was not so yeah
she wasn't doing it right and then uh
when we moved there she was already
living there so we would like talk to
her like hey what's up one day i came
over she was like showing me your place
and i was like why do you have all your
stuff covered in sheets does she look
like she just looked like a cool
unhygienic not really she just looked
like a cool she's like yeah come on over
i'll give you a tour of my home yeah she
would she would give me a tour and it
was like it was built in 1891. um this
is a crafting tour she had all these
things to say but i was like why did you
cover all your why is your stuff all
covered up but she was like i do art so
i don't want pink to get on my furniture
i was like it sounds good legit yeah and
then it wasn't weird until like uh like
months later she was like is it cool if
i put some of my trash in you guys bins
like the trash truck never picks mine up
she's like i think they're just
forgetting and i'm like why would the
trash not pick up your trash that's
weird yeah why are they going
[Music]
hail no they haven't been dead against
me
yeah so then that was like clue number
one and then uh and then it got really
bad when one did we do a party and then
um
the cop yeah someone did a noise
complaint and then the cop was like yeah
one of your neighbors is complaining i
was like well it can't be her because
she knew she's invited like she wasn't
the only complaint she's the closest one
to us and the guy was like the cops all
her who
and i was like why did you say that
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] was that and
then he like talked to his partner and
he was like looks like she's like now
she's over here it's this girl who um
she goes from house to house in
hollywood hills and she's like mental so
she starts to believe it's really her
house oh daddy she's a homeless yeah a
homeless squatter that she's like famous
because it can't arrest her because she
never does anything that wrong yeah
other than you know that but uh she they
can't get her out of the house easily
because you can't even tell her it's not
her house like in her brain it's
completely where she lives she has
parties and people over and everything
like it's normally her place it's crazy
well especially the way she sold that
backstory to you guys i know she
eventually she eventually got got out
because uh the cop said hey just so you
know you know like he's like you know
how squatters rights are it's really
hard so what you have to do is you gotta
be looking through her window and as
soon as you see her doing crack or
heroin then you can call the cops and
they can only take her out when she's
doing something illegal but isn't that
illegal for you to look through a window
not if it's within like reasonable view
oh yeah if i'm like [ __ ] you know
yeah
can't you crack your own house anymore
what's up with this man
kind of we live in it right yeah they
they then you can call then if they the
cops come and she's still doing crack
then they could take her out which we
did and she was so it was like perfect
you caught her smoke and crack yeah
absolutely you'll always catch yourself
and crack that's true every time that's
why they're like this is what everyone
does like you just have to wait till
they smoke crack yeah or something just
wait till they smell crack
she's smoking crack again so if she does
all the guys being illegal she could
just stay there she could stay there
until they settle it with the owner who
is like unreachable because this guy's
probably the ceo of 50 companies
somewhere and you know if you squat in a
place like for five years it's
technically
you you have rights to that place oh my
god no yeah no they could just steal
your [ __ ] you have rights to the place
holy [ __ ] stay over a certain amount of
time that's crazy that's probably what
she was working so i don't know why
she's part of the role how does she even
like detect all these empty
houses i bet they have systems bro like
in like even in our neighborhood
almost like i want to say out of 10
houses like two of them are empty
just because someone just owns it
sitting on it as a maybe like a a
conglomerate owns it or something not
even a person
you know what i mean yeah and if it just
sits long enough like these these people
that are walking like when homeless
people walk through the hollywood hills
not to be like a homeless hater but like
they're basically shopping like they're
not like they're scoping it out yeah
because you know if no one's in there
you know like when i had to kick a
homeless guy out from our backyard who
was like setting up his tent his
rationale was like no this house belongs
to the people
i was like why and who are the people
what and i think i think he was thinking
that i was also a squatter
and that i was trying he's like this
homeless guy yeah i think he thought
that i was
first and he was like he was like no
this is supposed like we're supposed to
share it
like i think he thought that like i just
beat him oh this bump hey at least i'm
not inside the house you bump
he's like i'm a respectable bum
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you